phéromone phéromone et féminin aussi
substance chimique et mise à petite dose
par un animal qui stimule une réponse
physiologique ou comportementale chez un
autre membre de son espèce exemple si
Dany dégage des phéromones pendant
l'émission moi je réagis et je dresse
affiche voilà
ah oui ça vous encourage à travailler
les grands mâles ils sont où en fait
ça dépend mais je connais un spot qui
est pas mal avec des très gros mâles qui
se réunissent
je vais peut-être me faire un slip avec
non mais Jérôme on va pas le manger
donc ça va bien non mais
ça pue carrément mais ça pue
cette émission est exceptionnelle cette
émission est unique vous allez voir avec
ce qu'on a fait ce que j'ai fait je
pouvais pas le faire deux fois c'est
vas-y vas-y
[Musique]
je te jure regarde Jérôme c'est un
attrape rêve en fait regarde
il est fou au cœur de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage c'est une baisse de
la durée d'indemnisation plus forte que
prévu annoncé par surprise à la veille
de Noël le gouvernement souhaite la voir
diminué de 40 % pour les demandeurs
d'emploi si le taux de chômage passe
sous les 6%. moi j'ai demandé plusieurs
fois j'avais demandé à Monsieur Ferrand
quand il était président de l'Assemblée
nationale comment il comptait donner
plus de prestations en faisant des
économies il a pas su me répondre j'ai
demandé à Madame borne quand elle était
ministre du Travail elle m'a dit les
prestations chômage ne baisseront pas
les allocations chômage ne baisse pas
elle l'a dit à la télé devant moi
visiblement sa baisse le principe de
base c'est celui-ci c'est dire la
situation économique s'améliore il y a
plein d'emplois pour voir donc on fait
un petit effort tout le monde fait un
petit effort aujourd'hui on est à 7,3
donc ça voudrait dire qu'il y aurait 25%
de durée d'indemnisation en moins
le taux de chômage à 6% et quelque chose
de possible je pense pas que ça sera
dans l'immédiat mais ça reste quand même
envisageable vous avez plusieurs
situations de marché du travail et pas
une seule et donc pour certains chômeurs
même à 6% du taux de chômage la
situation peut être extrêmement
difficile donc ces personnes-là peuvent
se retrouver à voir indemnisation
réduite alors même qu'elles ont du mal à
retrouver du travail le chiffre du
chômage pour le mois de novembre il est
en baisse de 2,1% précisément mais le
plancher des 3 millions de chômeurs
n'est pas encore franchi n'est pas
encore percé sur un an le recul on l'a
vu est de pratiquement 10% en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est pas parce
qu'il y a plus d'emplois plus
d'activités c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
radiations il y a beaucoup de radiations
quand Trump a été élu en faisant sa
politique sur les perdants de la
mondialisation donc un des endroits la
la ceinture rouillée où il y avait
l'équivalent du Nord de la France et les
plus d'usine et qui leur disait
américain ils se battent tout m'a dit
mais comment il peut avoir autant de
succès avec 5% de chômage une activité
et une économie aussi dynamique mais en
réalité c'est qu'il y avait plein de
gens qui sortaient des statistiques du
chômage mais qui n'avaient pas d'emploi
alors je fais quoi maintenant
il travaille
c'est moi qui me servir
que c'est lui en plus vous continuez à
manger j'espère que vous mangez bien
mais j'ai craché dedans de partir ça
veut dire que tous les radiés allaient à
l'alimenter un sac qui veut Macron
Macron il va finir son quinquennat il
aura ses 5% de chômage parce qu'il aura
tellement radié il pourra vous dire
regardez les amis je suis le premier
président
de chômage il aura radié plein de gens
et en même temps les mecs qui leur a
radié il toucheront rien ils seront dans
la nature comme ça mais depuis un an
conséquence de l'inflation il y a de
nouveaux profils de voleur alors
actuelle c'est plus une personne âgée
une personne retraité ça sera tout
simplement sa plaquette de beurre ça
sera son morceau de fromage son sa
tranche de jambon c'est c'est des
produits basiques qui ont eu une petite
hausse ou une eau s'avérer je pense
qu'il faut remettre les chômeurs au
travail à pas à moins d'être
professionnel pourquoi se révolter enfin
je veux dire est-ce que toi ce qui te
choque c'est qu'il y a des offres
d'emploi non pourvu et encore beaucoup
de monde
dans la restauration et Stéphane
manigole de l'a dit Mehdi Gaza aussi il
y a plein d'offres moi si jamais j'étais
au chômage je préfère en tant que
cerveau je serai absolument nul je ferai
tout tomber mais je préfère me lever et
faire comment tu peux aussi changer de
chaussures pour porter les plaques
ça c'est vraiment je sors pas de chez
moi
c'est imposture que l'on retrouve ici
toute chamboulé
une imposture Myriam s une supercherie
super voilà même pour l'ego qu'on a de
soi-même se lever le matin et gagner
quelque chose c'est plus gratifiant moi
quand j'étais étudiant je corrigeais des
copies je faisais 600 par mois ce qui
est quand même beaucoup chez pre barreau
je donnais des cours chez un cadeau bien
à Exelmans et en cumulant tout
j'arrivais à quelque chose donc quand on
cherche du système D on arrive à trouver
ça
c'est quoi c'est une boule de Noël
oh elle est mignonne et Nicolas Nicolas
ces caméras sont équipées d'un logiciel
qui repère les gestes suspects des
clients par exemple un objet qu'on va
mettre dans la poche ou alors quelqu'un
avec une poussette on va mettre on va
venir glisser en fin de compte un objet
en dessous on a deux virgules 2
milliards d'euros notre chiffre du jour
fera certainement réagir quelques
cheminots d'après nos confrères du
Parisien il s'agit du bénéfice record
réalisé cette année par la SNCF
2,2 milliards de profits comme vous
pouvez le voir je n'ai que deux sacs
normalement je devrais en avoir 8 ou 10
les Boxing Day ont été lancés hier au
Royaume-Uni et il y a beaucoup moins de
monde que d'habitude la fréquentation
des magasins a diminué d'un tiers par
rapport au niveau d'avant pandémie
pourtant ces soldes postes Noël sont à
rendez-vous très attendus dans le pays
dans un contexte d'inflation galopante
Richie sunac c'est montrer à ces
maladroit devant les caméras présentes
en posant une question à ce jeune homme
si l'intention était bonne au départ de
nombreux internautes ont fait part de
leur mécontentement l'homme à la tête de
la Grande-Bretagne ce serait montré
déconnecté du monde réel sa fortune très
élevée est souvent remise en cause